IF YOU DON’T LIKE IT, IT MAY BE
THEY WILL SEND SOME PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS TO YOUR HOUSE.
MARK MEADOWS IS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
WERE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
CONTINUING VIOLENCE IN KENOSHA.
IT HAS REACHED A POINT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING HURT HUGE
AMOUNTS OF PROPERTIES BEING
DESTROYED.
IT DOES SEEM OUT OF CONTROL.
WHY IS THIS BEING ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE?
>> IT IS OUT OF CONTROL AND IT
CAN’T BE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
OBVIOUSLY, I GOT A CALL TODAY
FROM THE CONGRESSMAN THAT
REPRESENTS THAT DISTRICT FROM
SENATOR JOHNSON AS WELL, REALLY
JUST PLEADING FOR HELP SAYING
THAT THE LOCAL SHERIFF AND THE
MAYOR AND POLICE CHIEF NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
I GOT ON THE PHONE RIGHT AWAY
AND OFFERED ASSISTANCE IN THE
FORM OF ADDITIONAL NATIONAL
GUARD HELP, AS YOU KNOW, THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE YOU HAVE TO
EITHER IGNORE THE PROBLEM WHICH
A LOT OF LIBERAL GOVERNORS ARE
DOING EXACTLY THAT, THEY ARE
IGNORING THE PROBLEM.
OR YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT AND
CONSEQUENTLY, WHEN YOU DEAL WITH
IT, YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
TO NOT LET THE WRITING GO.
YOU DO NOT HAVE A FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO LOOT INTO
RIOTS.
WHAT WE’RE SEEING ON THE STREETS
OF KENOSHA REALLY JUST BREAKS
OUR HEARTS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ON THE PHONE
WITH THE GOVERNOR TODAY AS WELL.
THE GENERAL FOR THAT NATIONAL
GUARD NEEDS ADDITIONAL HELP, WE
ARE THERE TO DO IT.
BUT THAT REQUEST WAS DENIED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
>> HE IS THE GOVERNOR OF
WISCONSIN, HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED,
THAT IN MY OPINION.
I KEEP THINKING, IF THESE WE’RE
RIGHT WING PROTESTERS AND THEY
WERE SCREAMING RACIAL EPITHETS
AND INTIMIDATING DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WOULD NOT ALLOW THAT TO
STAND FOR THREE MONTHS FOR A WHY
ARE THEY ALLOWING THIS?
I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
>> I CAN TELL YOU AS WE’VE GONE
IN, A COUPLE OF THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED BEHIND THE SCENE.
YOU’RE RIGHT, TUCKERED YOU HAVE
CALLED IT OUT VERY WE’VE MADE
ACTUAL 99 ARREST IN PORTLAND.
IN PORTLAND, THEY WANT EVEN
ARREST PEOPLE AND IF THEY ARREST
THEM, THEY LET THEM OUT THE NEXT
DAY.
IT’S JUST A PERPETUAL PROBLEM
THAT YOU HAVE.
THAT IS WHY WHEN WE LOOK AT IT,
WE HAVE TO DO A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR
WITH ME, WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH, IT’S
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RESTORE THE SAFETY OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES SETTING UP A TASK
FORCE TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME OF
THAT FEDERAL RATS REST THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
EVEN IN ADDITION TO THAT, PEOPLE
OF KENOSHA, THE PRESIDENT IS
WILLING TO HELP, IT’S TIME WE
TAKE CONTROL.
HOPEFULLY THE NUMBER OF NATIONAL
GUARD THEY HAVE IN TONIGHT WILL
ACTUALLY RESTORE PEACE.
AM NOT OPTIMISTIC.